the st louis archbishops playing the
dallas destiny
in the western conference finals the
winner will advance to the championship
match december 1st
so we have the white pieces and i'm
right here with uh four-time us chess
champion yasser sarawan welcome yasser
to the show thank you pleasure to be
with you mike
so so this match is very exciting it's
uh we're the number two seed against uh
the dallas destiny they won the division
based off of a
tiebreaker they had more uh game points
than we had match points and that's
critical because because they get the
draw out however we got the color choice
so we're gonna have whites on boards one
and three
and black on boards two and four okay
well let's start with
uh game number uh board number two then
where we have varacobian playing black
representing uh st louis archbishops of
course versus lee
from dallas and lee opened uh e4
and it's kind of funny we got a lot of
french defenses right as expected right
three out of four games or
were expected french defenses well at
least in this one
unfortunately uh var was about five
minutes late for this encounter so
that's why uh there's a disparity on the
time is uh
as such okay
so we have a standard uh
french with knight c3
knight f6 the stein its variation and
then bishop g5 this move was actually
made
popular by alexander alakine
and it gives black additional options
that he wouldn't have
in the uh troops excuse me i did
something wrong there i apologize uh
that he wouldn't have in the traditional
variations which go
yeah i have to write in pardon me
uh copy
sorry i should have done this earlier
copy game
six i believe
just a second sorry copy game six
yes okay
so we go back to where i
i had wanted to be
and we were here knight c3 knight f6
bishop g5
and instead of bishop g5 let me go back
the
okay i can't do what i wanted to do i
guess i can only do what i want to do
when i get to the game uh position when
you get to the yeah
the stopping point huh okay so we have
it takes on e4
yes the stopping point that's a good way
of putting it bishop e7 bishop takes gf
black accepts a kind of double pawn
structure uh double death pawns in
return for the two bishops and funnily
enough this pawn on on
f6 can actually control some important
key squares now do you think four will
ever get the castle in this position
it really depends usually uh
the simple answer is no
okay and most of the variations that
come from this particular variation
black's king just camps out in the
center
so knight c3 so knight c3
leaves open the option
for white of being able to advance his
d-pawn now var played a7 a6 which is a
really a hyper aggressive
uh
way of playing this specific position
i'm much more familiar with bishop f6
okay but this was var's choice a6 he
wants to expand on the queen side
and it's sort of like a
it's not really a sicilian but you can
understand why
in many sicilians black wants to play b5
b4 and drive the knight out of the
center queen e2 b5 and there he goes b4
so he's he's kind of like sidelined
this knight on a4
but at the cost of his king still being
in the center and he hasn't competed
completed his piece development queen d5
now at this point
both players would be out of the book i
think it's still book you're thinking i
think it's still book okay uh
for sure it's for sure still look queen
c4 now this is upon sacrifice i think
it's been tried on a couple of occasions
personally
i'm not a big fan of sacrificing pawns
when i'm black i don't mind doing it
when i'm white
but when i'm black i would have probably
traded queens but var goes for the
sharpest line which is to
give away his c pawn wow
and now
queen drops back there's a threat of
knight b6 which he addresses
so in return for just
just upon the c pawn you can see that
black has really good piece development
and his two bishops are actually working
very very nicely but having said that
he's still upon down
b2b3 what that move does is it sets up a
retreat knight b2 knight c4 in a lot of
variations besides just
not hanging the a2
okay
rook g8 now after the move rook g8 you
can see it's really really hard for
white to untangle his pieces he can't
move his bishop he can't move his rook
on h1 he can move his king but that
doesn't help address his development
problems with the move knight e1 it's a
slow slow idea but white wants to play
f3
then he wants to play g3 then he wants
to develop his bishop and so forth and
so on
king e7
king stays in the center
bishop e2 now you can't take twice on g2
because there's a rook in the corner on
a8 bishop f3 will
double attack both rooks at the end of
that variation so the rook moves out now
finally var is ready to capture back his
pawn and it's very hard for white to
defend the pawn in fact the only move is
bishop f3
so white maintains his extra pawn but
now his extra pawn has been doubled as
well double isolated yeah yeah
bishop f4 check and i think we're up to
date probably the move king b1 it keep
it b2 open for tonight exactly so we've
got
such ideas as knight b2 to d3 or knight
b2 to c4 and bringing the knight to more
active square
now in the meantime one of the things
that var has done he's done it very
successfully is he's isolated this pawn
over here so oftentimes there's an idea
of bringing your rook across to attack
the pawn
uh i would probably if i were in black
shoes i would probably play the move
knight f6 yeah at this point
i would want to put my knight nicely
like night here you want to play for
tricks like knight e5 or anything
oh is that c
but i mean fine i don't know if it does
anything it takes
it takes advantage of the short term pin
along the d file but i got f3 covered so
i could probably play knight b2 now
threatening to capture
well i don't know i mean at least in
this case you can redirect your energy
uh towards the d4 pawn so there's
something to be said for
i i would probably
offer
force you to
mess up your palm structure in terms of
taking it
all right let's so so the final analysis
of this position is
var is down upon but he's doing okay
yeah he's got a for sure he's got com
calm
okay let's just uh reduce that for a
moment and we'll go to
our number one board
and let me just bring this up for a
second yeah is the us chess league all
about so the us chess league is a
four on four team uh competition
it's uh played over the internet chess
club we're obviously playing in the
chess club and scholastic center in the
vip boardroom our team is all assembled
there and
dallas is playing um
somewhere in uh dallas obviously
so
probably all in the same location as
well
that's justly for you
it's a requirement in the chess league
that the players be under the
observation of a arbiter
uh so that you know there's no outside
and interference or any help and that's
one of the things that i really do like
about the chess league even though we
geographically the country's so huge
that it's a real challenge to put
together a league
if you do it over the internet you just
have to control make sure everything's
okay and that's one of the things i
really admire about the chess league
there's never been any issues of any
cheating of anything like that and the
players are really confident that
they're playing against one another yeah
definitely our uh td is uh jonathan
trans who does uh
the opening lecture on monday and uh you
know very confident and he makes sure
you know everybody's obeying all the
rules yep and jonathan recently was the
assistant arbiter at tv uh here for the
two matches yeah yeah the exhibition
match yeah showdown in saint louis
showdown in southern lewis okay we go to
the game between nizhnak uh
uh against hold now this is a good one
this is a revenge match actually in the
last uh last day of the regular season
uh
niche nick actually lost to holt with
the black pieces okay so now he's got
the white piece so he's really geared up
for this match he knows he's in for a
tough opponent so i'm very excited to
see how this is progressing so hold
obviously has a reputation of a french
defense player
and it's intriguing to me
that nishnak
chose the exchange uh french defense
usually this is not considered a
challenge for black
but when you follow it up with the move
c25
it's not going to be a quiet game
right niche nick said before the game
that he was going all in in this game so
he's gonna go for the win he does not
want to draw he just wants to win this
thing well and unfortunately because of
the tie break uh draw odds favor right
we got to make hay with the white pieces
right all right
let's see what happened after knight f6
knight c3 takes takes so white accepts
an isolated uh queen pawn for better
development and more space
but on the other hand black's uh
position is very solid cat
h3 i'm not a big fan of h3 i understand
that after the desirable bishop g5
black for his in his part plays bishop
g4
and after d5 he's got a comfortable game
with knight e5
having said that there's still
this pin
does give some um
let us say troubles right we're
retreating now yeah so instead of
retreating we'll just play the
prophylactic h3 and just stop all the
shenanigans well fine but then after the
prophylactic h6
the shenanigans for white has been
stopped and this bishop on c1 really
doesn't have that brighter future all
right let's see how it goes
queen c2 just developing
not a big fan i don't think the queen is
particularly effective on c2 but let's
see
there are issues pardon me let me make a
bad move for black for just a moment
there are issues here if you make a bad
move let me just put a bad move on the
position there is a tactic like bishop
takes h6
g takes h6 a sacrifice queen g6 check
beautiful which is
spoken as a true team captain beautiful
uh that black has to be careful of hence
we see the move knight a5 to get that
bishop off the diagonal off the diagonal
for those of you who remember kasparov
karpov matches
um
you'll recall that in a number of those
matches karpov as white actually played
the move h
a2 a3 in order to keep his bishop on
this diagonal
so like i said i'm not a big fan of
queen c2 having said that let's see how
the game progressed knight a5 bishop d3
bishop e6 blacks developing and again
white has a question what am i really
doing with this bishop on c1
rookie one rookie 895.
now we know what white is doing white
wants to play the move bishop f4
bring his other rook to d1 then he's
fully developed and he can start looking
for the attack
black has to stop white from getting a
very
comfortable position and so plays the
move knight c6
after the trade well at least white has
doubled up right lacks bonds but it's
hard to get to
a weakness is a is only a weakness if it
can be attacked
a2a3 a little bit of a prophylactic move
may be white sometimes one again wants
to gain space over here with b4
queen d7 by the way queen d7 sets up
his own little little sacrifice cheapo
that you have to be keep it careful of
it for
94 knight takes e4 bishop takes e4
now
yeah
so we got bishop f5 2 on it
taking advantage of the pin
the bishop came out we see a trade and i
think we're up to date yeah that's how i
play what rook that he uh well no you
can't play that you can't play now
because of the chat yeah
but let's say he plays a move well let's
just say he stops playing games and he
just says take it take it
rook over
let's say queen
i don't know
queen c2
again these pawns are a weakness but
it's still hard to get at them and i i'm
thinking it's still a balanced game for
example rook to e6 right well is our
d-pawn also a weakness for white's
d-pawn
yes and black will probably have to
spend quite a number of moves going
after it's pretty easy defend by the way
i've got this move bishop e3 and if
you're not
careful
this pawn on a7 can get targeted very
quickly
all right let's go on to our third board
let me just uh
see what we've got here
so the third board is uh spencer has the
uh white pieces national master spencer
feingold ben feingold's son against uh
national master
atulia vayetti
from uh dallas so
atulia is having a very good year this
year in the uh chess league four and a
half out of five with only doug eckert
drawing them in that uh well that wild
in the wild game yes wow what a match
okay
very very nice let's see what we have we
have the king's indian defense we're
gonna go from the beginning
uh d4 by spence
at f6
so we get all of these nice moves that
signify the king's indian bishop e2 the
traditional main line if you will e5 and
the petrosian variation which is this
early that's that's what spencer said he
was going to play so he's got exactly
what he wants at this point
that's always nice
plays into your preparation let's see
how good spencer's preparation is so the
move a5 a very common theme in the
king's indian
is that black wants to secure
this outpost c5 for his knight and he
first does does that by playing a5
so it makes it very difficult for white
to boot that knight with the move b2 b4
so so far now h3 hmm
i'm not a big fan of that move obviously
it's preparation by spencer if i was
working with spencer before the match i
would have suggested bishop g5 i'm not a
big fan of the move h now unlike in the
niche knicks game where if you played
bishop g4 you know you would have to
retreat bishop e2 and and do all that so
i i am actually a fan of your bishop
move and this situation this encounter
because you're not losing any temple by
retreating yeah and you're not afraid of
bishop g4 the what so having said all of
that why would white play h3
oftentimes as we know any king's indian
black source of counter players to play
f7f5 the move h3 sets up a kind of um
a picket fence he white plays for the
move g4 so that whenever f5 is played
you can take with the g pawn and open up
the g line for your rook vis-a-vis
black's kings so in this position
spencer
probably won't castle either side or
mostly queenside queenside okay yeah
mostly queenside okay knight a6 bishop
g5
queen e8 now this is a very key move
actually a very important moment
especially for kings indian defense
players
oftentimes this pin
is very uncomfortable for black because
it's so necessary for get for black to
get into tempo f7fi
so this he doesn't like this knight
being on the f6 square queenie eight's a
nice move by the way because in a in a
weird sense
even though the position is absolutely
closed all all 16 pawns are on the board
the queen actually observes
both directions e8 and h5 as we'll see
in a second why the move queen e8 is is
a key move
knight d2
so that stops any knight h4 ideas
because you'll just rip the knight once
it lands on h5
king h8 very good move by black black
prepares to move
to retreat as knight in order to get
this liberating move f7 f5
h4 well there you go so you go h3
h4
or you know you think to yourself well
wasn't there a better use of a tempo on
the queen side wouldn't it be better if
i played a3 or b3
okay h4 h6 uh
hmm
first impression is i don't like that
move but okay uh i'm i'm basically sure
the players are both in their theory
book still
knight h7
again
straightforward black is
not being stopped so he just gets g4 in
there guys
wow but i'm not a big fan of bismuth
boy i mean wait when are these guys
going to play a move that i really
really like so they're playing like
they're writing yeah playing like grand
masters i'm not enthusiastic uh why play
g you've played h4 uh in the words of
the immortal ben larson having said a
you must say b you played h4 you got to
play h5 so then g5 g5 is a terrible move
because now after g4 that's it the whole
black king side is shut down there's no
f7 f5s
you will be able to play knight to f1
to g3 to f5 and you'll get a
a crushing strategical bind after h5 he
has to play f5
takes
queen takes
and now it kind of gets a messy roddy
position it's kind of hard to say who
stands better except white has a
superior pawn structure at the moment
there's a weakness on g2
but this was not what spence played
spencer played
g4
f5
takes takes takes takes
knight e4
knight f6
bishop f3 queen g6 now we can really see
why that move queen e8 was so useful got
out of the pin and as it turns out the
queen is now putting pressure on the e4
knight now let's see what happened after
we're up to date i believe with the play
so how many so yeah he's got a lot of
players on uh
e4 right now coming down so spencer's
got to address that situation
immediately right now
uh a big question
is is you want to play h5 queen here
uh
in these types of positions
it's gonna be a long one it's a bond
burner one of the uh
key questions in positions like this is
the position of the kings the respective
positions of the king
right now you might think to yourself
that well black's king has no great
shakes on h8 but actually
it's in the corner it's well defended
yeah look at how many pieces he's got
surrounding them helping them out so
i think it's going to be tough for
spencer to crack through that exactly
and spencer on the other hand his king
is in the center and
normally speaking it's easier for black
when the king is in the center to attack
so
um
if he were to trade let's say just
knight takes e4 and that's just for
argument's sake bishop takes f6 on the
board
the problem is white's still a long way
away from um
solving the riddle of what do i do with
my king well you got queen to d2
if you would take back with the bishop
picking up the temple because we're
attacking h6 here
right
i probably will ignore that threat
and play a move like night before
uh checking here or maybe
checking here where i got a little fork
uh going yeah don't and no castle in
this position anybody
don't do this at home you're
so uh there are some issues here for
uh spencer
and my first impression is i
would rather
overall have black's position i'm not a
big fan of this pawn on h4
if this were on g1 it would make all the
difference in the world frankly uh
that's a very important
attacking move to have in and with the
queen on g6 it stops that what about uh
knight to g3 in this position yeah
that's also a very good move uh
you're not trading off this knight which
at the moment blocks that bishop so it's
nice to leave the knight back on g3 the
question is can you exploit
the fact that you've encouraged this
bishop that was on f5
to move into your camp on d3 so black
has ideas like might before knight c2 as
we've seen before
it might be just threatening to take
that pawn
so knight g3 bishop d3
uh
you don't want to play move like b3
because that really does encourage
black to play e4 which you know there's
latent threats
uh along the
h8 a1 diagonal
so
i like the move knight g3
bishop d3 now i have to decide how can i
kick
this bishop
out while we try to get tricky yes with
rook g1 now rook g1 now
okay so just show us what you want to do
you want to you you wanted to
i just want to be tricky yeah you wanted
to have a tempo against the queen on a
good day i get it i really do
um
but again white's king still in the
center of the board
and you're vulnerable to this night for
how about uh
you can stop this at any time how about
king to d2 here
so now our queen is protecting her rook
and our knight is free to uh
rock and roll right with the discovery
okay
not that i
and the more that i look i don't see any
good discoveries here right so if i go
bishop take c4
i mean it would be great if you could
play knight f5 then you would be gaining
a discovery and you'd probably be
winning a piece the problem is with the
move bishop c4
i'm i've set up for a big check big
check a big fat check right here in the
middle of the board
well i'm glad spencer's playing this
game and not me
if st louis is glad yes
the whole the whole religion
the whole town
the whole town's happy but okay so
spencer's got some issues that he's got
to address let's go to our last board
which has actually been a very
interesting game
yeah rosenthal nicholas rosenthal he
goes to a lindenwood university
he's been tearing up the chess league
this year he's uh seven out of eight
this year and he won his uh his
quarterfinal matchup as well so we're
very happy to have him on the uh
team this year
he's been terrific absolutely
okay and uh
dare i say yet another french defense
uh
rosenthal has actually been very loyal
to the french defense and he's done very
well with it throughout not just this
season but uh his chess career
and this is the traditional steinitz
variation a7 a6 remarkably
you know for for a variation that
literally is a hundred years old
and has had
thousands of games been played there's a
large number of moves for for black that
you can't believe
uh there is the traditional move a7 a6
oops let me go back to the start and do
it a different way i bet you're firm
okay i'm just i'm going to do this i beg
your pardon
oops
oh that was interesting i got an update
how cool is that
okay now where's my
controls give me yeah there we go
okay and i want to go back to the
beginning but then i want to go move my
move there we go
okay so
what i wanted to say is you get to this
position
and before you see the move a6
uh in the past f5 was played the idea
was that since white wants to want to
one day play f5 you just get it in and
you say i'm blocking up the position
that used to be an old treatment an
ultra modern
treatment was upon sacrifice g5 i
haven't seen that oh no one one of
nakamura's
favorite gambits actually used to play
it in tons of blitz games
more alexander maurizevich one of the
most creative players in in the chess
world today has been experimenting with
b7 b6
and
and finally there's also this well well
trodden path this is a
i even believe they call it the french
end game
where
black just trades off everything
white has a square d4 that he often uses
like this
but uh
afghani body have michael gurvich some
of the world's top grand masters
alexander chernin have played this
position for black
they like it
even though white slightly better
gary kasparov won against bariev an
absolutely fantastic game from that
ending so a6
is the long time traditional mainline
move everything is okay up to here and
this move bishop d3
is
a surprise move for me i think everybody
and his brother has played bishop e2
traditionally
bishop d3 and the first time i saw that
i said oh my god d4 wins a piece
and i thought that was it
and i thought that
the white player from dallas had
overlooked d4 but apparently this looks
to me
like he had everything under control
thanks to this move bishop e4 white is
not losing a piece as both the knight on
d4 as well as the bishop on a8 it's a
double attack
now that was a um
move that's not actually how this game
progressed is it yes this is okay so
where this is the actual game now knight
b6 was actually a very bold move by
rosenthal i thought he was going to play
knight take c2 check
giving back the piece bishop takes c2
bishop takes e3 queen takes e3
and
white's a little bit better thanks to
his space
yeah but
material materialist right right
materially they're even but that was not
what he did he played knight b6
b3 oh wow
that is wild
i would i thought that bishop takes a8
knight takes a8 castles is simply
excellent for white
thanks to this
uh pin on the d file
as well as this bishop on e3 attacking
c5 but it's very clear
to me now after the move b3 that
white wanted to stop
knight c4
ooh
very handsome
double attack if the queen moves then
knight takes e3 yeah and then
even i can see this
all of st louis is uh buzz with joy
right so we saw the move b3 okay
now did rosenthal have a good follow-up
against b3
rook a7 all right now we can swing the
rook yeah whoa
jennifer shahadi would be so proud right
now
rook d7 so black's a piece up
and white has better come up with
something really good
f5 and i think we're up to date with f5
whoa
now why did nick play f5
okay a queen f2 what is white's threat
i suppose it's so
something as slow as rook d3 and rook d1
okay
the cheerleaders cannot be restrained
right
my goodness okay
so now all rosenthal has to do
is consolidate his extra keys yes sir
but it's not so easy
if you want some people hit me up all
right thank you sir yeah they treat us
right at kingside diner right next door
at the uh chess club
okay
so we're seeing this kind of
remarkable move f5 i would not have
guessed that move at all i i would have
looked at b4
maybe it's not a good move but i would
have certainly given it my attention the
idea is i'm hoping
that
black pardon me white will allow me to
to trade right
very very nicely
but after b4 the knight would be driven
to a passive square you certainly would
not want to play the move knight a4
because that
lets me really gummy up your pawn i mean
that's really what what black wants to
do on this position right is get his
bishop to a7
protected by his rook so he will
well maybe not well i'm just thinking
that in any case to gain some space
might after b4 the knight is driven back
um
castle
rook to d3
and
it's a wild position
i'd have a hard time making heads or
tails out of this if i wanted to play f5
i could always get that move in but as
it is what he did is he played f5 right
away
now clearly
um
if you get the bishop to drop back to d3
then you're really really happy because
then the pressure on the d file has been
neutralized the big question is
how will the game continue after takes
on poisson
queen takes f6
looks right right
rook d3
castles
rook d1
rook d8 and
black has maintained his extra
piece
for the time being
the variation this variation may
continue bishop h7 check
king h7
knight e4
attacking the queen attacking the bishop
now before you get yourself all excited
and say move your queen and i end up
capturing on d4
one variation you got to keep in mind is
whoa
where did that come from
knight takes d3 check
with the nasty
evil intention of queen
and this would be winning for black
so there's no bishop takes sacrifice
maybe this is just a good position for
black and maybe
nikki's a genius
with f5
what about bishops
c6
clearly pinning i am for i'm obliged to
take
knight takes c6 bishop takes
c5
now i've got one pawn for the piece but
i don't
think it should be sufficient
after knight d5 i mean i've got
domination on the dark squares that's
good
that's very good in fact but
it shouldn't be worth an entire piece
right i think white's objective in this
position is to keep all the pressure on
the d file and not
not give it up for for anything at this
point because
you know he's down a piece right yeah
well you want to get it you got to try
to get that knight back at all costs
well the other line that we could
consider is takes on f6 takes on f6 now
move like b4
looks really sharp to my eyes and i can
easily imagine imagining
imagine that this would rebound
against
white and in black's favor
for example knight e2 jack
you can't take with the knight because
of the very pretty
check made in one move that is clear to
us
if you take with the queen
then queen takes and now you're
threatening bishop takes
e3 check so how about bishop take c5
isn't this wonderful for black
life
no it's not
same because after queen a3 chat oh
pardon me when you're a one b
it's just flat
i wanted to point out uh a well-known
pattern
shack
made is better than check by the way
night oops sorry night here and the
well-known patterns of mates
that occur either on the b2 or a2 square
so this is all looking
to be in black's favorite so no b4 is
what i'm saying here
good
good
all right let's but yeah i i hope
for oliver's things that nick nick uh
nikki takes back with the queen because
yeah there's a lot of great things going
on in that dangle if his opponent does
capture ump assange well besides
ampassad you really don't want to step
back because that means that black got
this very useful tempo in for free or
you just you just flat out take the
bishop right or castle first just get
your king into safety you can wait for
this rook to
slide over and you can always one day
end up capturing this bishop over here
the only thing about
castling first if you take knight takes
bishop bishop takes bishop attacks the
rook right off the bat
oh sure but uh but for example after
bishop f3 castles right
uh
if you play rook d3 first of all i
really want to toss
this move uh before in super badly just
to like
get this knight to go into you know some
kind of horrible
uh
go back crawl yeah yeah yeah now i got a
lot of the dark squares over here nice
and uh happy um
let's just let's put some moves on the
board for a second what can we do
that i like um
let's say
boom boom boom
how about this is a move uh queen c7
first of all
so i've got some evil intentions of i'm
looking towards this
this pawn on c2
how what do i mean by that let's say
knight rook here
i'm looking at an idea like knight take
c2
just to expose
white's queen oh oh i'm gonna expose his
king a little sorry maybe bishop c3
there's no real way
of taking advantage of this
nice line
hmm
i was hoping to uh make some very nice
tactics work i'm not
i don't think i did a very good job
in that position couldn't you just
consolidate
um after knight
well i played knight takes c2 i could
you i could consolidate like this oh oh
no even in that even then that knight
takes c2 line yes so knight takes bishop
takes
rook takes rook takes
now queen takes
oh but we're going to be down
in any event we'd be down uh
yeah yeah
no right at the moment
at the moment material is dead even by
the way and maybe this line is actually
still quite okay for black after let's
say queen takes queen takes i mean it's
dead even but i was i was trying to
actually look for a line that's very
promising for black
and i didn't find it with the queen e7 i
have to do a little bit better i could
even potentially play
slowly a5 and just come out here
to grab this rook if the rook drops back
to d2 i'll grab this bishop
so you're right even though when you do
grab this bishop
um
i've got i've got a pretty nice position
here actually for for for black i'm
happy
let us see what's happening in the other
boards but okay so far it's going to
have been a pretty tough
match
we'll see how uh
how
rosenthal's opponent eventually
replies to f5 there okay let's just get
in fact let's uh let's get updated on
what actually happened in the game
okay i think it's game eight right copy
game
eight
okay wow
okay so what actually happened
we've seen this position
this was the bishop e4 variation
oh i did something wrong
i apologize let me go
fast to uh position and get a nice recap
of the game yeah exactly so okay so just
turn it in here's like here's the game
and now now we saw this move b3 and we
were expecting rook a7 yes
castles rook d7 queen f2
f5
oh sorry
right away position oh okay we were
looking at ampassam mainly yes and white
did not like those positions and i
understand why
knight c4 wow let's see if we can't
understand what's going on
because this is
very confusing for me
okay
let's let's do
the obvious bishop takes why not
sure we're attacking this knight here
we're attacking this bishop here
but white has the move
bishop takes d4 attacking this knight
so we could trade or
can we just take the the bishop in this
instance and then get the get the knight
back
so rook takes oh no no no no no no no
no no don't don't stop yourself here
you've sacrificed an exchange but look
at white's exposed king you can always
get the exchange back with bishop c5 so
this might have been a very decent well
line two so if
if the bishop takes
on b4 which is our main move and then
bishop takes our main reaction
now and this
the problem is we would really like to
play knight c4
but then we have to analyze the the
consequences
and they are complicated consequences of
bishop c6 i still think this is a good
position for
black
for example the move queen a5 sets up
the threat of check and checkmate
if you take the rook you've still got
to address this threat
if you go back something tells me this
king is not very happy camper down here
there i mean black is looking really for
choice
so i like
uh black's position after the move b4
was played
but he played knight c4
so knight c4
is a clear indication he wants to go
queenie because we see those patterns
all the time we see those checkmating
patterns but he takes it okay and now
it's black to play and
whether it's good or bad that's a
different issue but it's for in my
opinion it's a certainty that when he
played knight c4 his expectation was
queen a5 yeah let's go i'm gonna go get
you in a checkmate because your king is
so exposed now so the knight is under
attack on c3 and we've got a devastating
check here correct
so let's try to address both those
issues
by dropping our knight back so now our
knight's
not under attack and we're defending the
square now
the straightforward line that you know
like everybody wants to do is all right
takes a2 but it doesn't look like it's
gonna
work because bishop takes well it
doesn't mean it's the end of the line
necessarily again black
isn't a piece down he's
may not be a piece ahead but this queen
you know even if the computer says no
checkmate
between two humans we don't like that
queen being an uninvited
and now we have a great move if white
would pass with e3
okay i'll pass you mean
because after e3 i can't take it right
and if i'm forced to move the queen
you wanted to
take the bishop which is a nice idea of
course
and set up for a mate so this looks
pretty attractive to me
let's uh but let's see if it's uh
uh if the game i would be by the way
we're uh we're on to something here
we're on i would be shocked if rosenthal
did not play uh queen a5 well you will
not have to be shot mike because
remarkably enough he did play queen a5
and knight c3 was in fact
uh the reaction of white now queen takes
a2 is not forced either uh
we could hold off on that move we could
take the bishop
so we could set white up for a cheapo if
he takes with the rook now he's got no
bishop d4 answer to queen
too so he probably have to take with the
mission sir
now we could get our king out of hawk
maybe set up ideas of rook to and i like
that tactic that you mentioned very much
in fact i like that idea of e3 as a
decoy i mean right yeah i loved it by
the way when i was a kid even though i
didn't understand um
the tactic very well i like the word
yeah decoy
man he's just like it's an exciting word
exactly yeah i got him with the decoy
and
he collapsed you know what can i say so
we're looking good that is to say st
louis and we're very partial by the way
this is not an impartial yes i am the uh
the manager of the uh the team so yeah
we're not we're not neutral on this uh
i'll get in trouble
yeah
diamond captains are dying a dozen of
these days there's a lot of captains out
there that need a job
keep walking keep looking
move along nothing to see no occupancy
let's go okay let's see
our game one let's bring this um
our first board
all right we're back to uh the niche
nick holt game
and i think it's
game
five
yes all right get back there is a god he
loves me okay um when we left it we'll
just go back
we were back around we were looking at
actually an end game very
yeah this was what we saw we they
followed our analysis okay rookie two
king f1
and
again white is
probing here i'm not saying it's a big
advantage or anything like that he's
simply pro probing these pawns are more
vulnerable than the d4 pawn queen b7
okay
by the way i think that was a very good
plan by holt
to trade bishops and now they're in a
queen upon ending
and this move was a very good move
activate because basically what white
wanted to do was bring his king up to c3
and very very
uh slowly just simply squeeze his
opponent off the board well with the
queen coming here there's a check on the
back right that rules that out and
there's also the activation move queen
e4
and normally speaking queen end games
are so difficult that whenever there are
perpetual checks in the position the
chances of a draw are much higher
than the chances of the win
yeah so this looks
i'm going to say i pray i would rather
play white
but it's closer to a draw than a win
smaller value and and you don't think
there's
any possibility of a queen trade uh holt
would probably never go for a queen
trade in this position this should be
very
uh
leery let's put it that way of trading
queens uh basically he wants to activate
his queen keep it on the board and get
play as many checks as he possibly can
yep yep yep so well
so here for example it might look
very sensible to play a move like queen
to c5 it looks attractive
you're attacking a7 you're attacking g5
and you're thinking that if you
do
take the pawn on a7 you've got
a
an
express
to promotion however the problem is
is that black plays queen e4 not
worrying about either one of his pawns
if you take the pawn on g5 then black is
very happy taking this one on d4 if you
take the pawn on a7 black is very happy
taking this one and suddenly
again black is closer to perpetual
checks
than white i mean white is a long way
from
yeah looking good so if i had to win if
i had to guess
i'm going to predict right now half half
on this game yep okay hopefully not not
the whole the whole uh the whole match
because if obviously if the uh the match
is drawn uh bye-bye bishops it's uh
onboard the championship for dallas all
right so let's go to our
board 2 we're going to come back to lee
ukopian so now this puts the onerous on
the rest of the archbishops to win which
rosenthal is taking the
he looks good the steam so now let's see
what a kobe can can figure out hopefully
he can exactly get us get us a point
here
the whole point the whole point
of the game
because essentially we would have to go
two out of three if game one ends in a
draw right we'll happen too there we go
okay so when we left it uh we were in
parts and well known
there was a bishop check
uh we like king b1 because we wanted to
keep the b2 square up unoccupied mike
you're gonna have to take a bow
you can't resist the trick who cares if
we're going to have a nice centralized
knight on a d5 when you can do a
trick like that
you know i was the coach in the 1988
world championship cycle of viktor
korchnoy
and i had such an example where you know
a move i suggested was played and victor
looked at me with disgust and he said
something to the effect that well
every now and then the blind chicken
finds
the corn
the seed cork you know okay
thank you for the compliment i get it
you know
uh 95
okay it does have a very direct idea you
know you want to pressure the spine on
d4
hence came the move c4 now why would you
play c4 well it does give you the square
c2 to go to protect this pawn in case
that pawn
is directly attacked and after the
amphison well the knight on a4 gets to
come back so this looks pretty
reasonable by the way oh that looks
knight
came back nonetheless to c6
now knight c2 okay
so there was there must have been a very
specific reason that white rejected d5
let's see if we can't figure it out
ourselves
so after the move d5
uh let's move our knight here to b4
attacking this pawn for the third time
and if you capture trying to maintain
your extra wood
material there may be this very obscure
looking bishop d2
that
throws white off for the moment
black you remember black sacrificed upon
ages ago for activity remember keep in
mind this rook on h1 doesn't look that
great and neither this is knight on e1 i
suspect
this is what lee did not like which is
why he played
the move knight c2
but now having played knight c2
there comes rook g2
ecobee and brooks
excellent
it looks like black's a clear favorite
to win back his pawn
now comes the move d5 knight switches
back to e5
now a lot of white pawns are on priest
rook to d4
straightforward idea of attacking the
bishop
whoa
this is either very cool
or
something's wrong
i i mean it's
it's one or the other it's either a very
very cool sacrifice
or
ocobian has missed something okay let's
see if we can to understand
so rook takes f4 i attacked the bishop
you didn't move it i took it
your turn
now one of the things we notice
is that this knight is on pre
or rather it's under attack but it's
defended by the king the next thing we
notice is that these two knights
aren't protected and the sea file is
open
so we start to think
that a cobian's idea is related to
the knights in the middle in midair so
to speak okay
now we can't defend
white cannot defend the knight on
on uh
with king to b2 because the simple
knight d3 check will force the king away
and that's all she wrote
so
this is for sure what a cobian has in
mind then
prediction if a cobia wins this game
he'll get a game of the week for sure
for that move i mean that's for uh by
our standard
game of the month
top agent of the day award i mean let's
get serious you know like okay so this
is
so maybe this is why white's hesitating
you know grand masters you know when
they offer you pawns and pieces just
don't take them right away you know i
mean
these guys don't give things away for
free you know i mean
no free lunches in st louis i can tell
you
okay so rook d4 so one more time
rook takes f4 rook c3 do we have
some things about like throwing in a
check
then you can throw in the rook check and
well one one cheapo that i like is you
can't play king f6 because of oops
that's a horrible fork that's a real
messed up fork but
don't put your king there
oftentimes it's overlooked by amateurs
in the sense that they like to win pawns
i like to win tonight but sometimes you
can use your opponent's pawns as a
natural shield for your own king so you
could play a move for example
like king d7 and say ha ha ha ha
you can't check me because that pawn
actually
gives me protection
so i like this move king d7
and let's go back and move
if this knight were simply to move
something like well that's really
helping black
now the rooks
are doubled and it's all very nice for
black
if the knight were to move another way
for example out here
then that's even worse because
uh we call this uh two pigs on the
seventh
and they're greedy those rooks are
so um
this might just work out
very well
for var so it looks like var in addition
to playing well obviously
possibly the best yeah he's uh
he's gaining on time as well from his uh
his time deficit in the opening yeah and
you mentioned his lateness to the to to
to uh the game and that actually is
because he had to fly in from l.a right
yes yes he flies in for l that's how
much of a team player he is you know
he's dedicated to the team immensely
right and uh we appreciate that for sure
okay so that's bars game rose and whoa
let's go to that road is that a knockout
by now it look it's looking really good
as a team captain you're gonna i'm ready
to i'm ready to write that one down
i understand but look what has happened
all right when we left it
we'll go back a few moves
we left it about these parts that was
where
uh nick came up with the move
knight c4 takes queen a5 we saw that
coming from a long ways away knight came
back to b1
92 chat that one was not
we saw a number of occasions that we
were trying these 92 to check kind of
tactics so let's see queen takes a2
queen takes a2 with the the clever idea
of knight e2
is a moment ago there would have been a
bishop on d4 and a queen on f2 remember
so
uh nikki's idea is if white tries to
stop at the mate
the bishop is not protected by the queen
so queen b2 is coming regardless
so instead
after 92 check takes queen takes
basically essentially he's saying is
you can't cover the b2 square
you saw rook takes d7 queen b2 check
king d1
bishop what
now why did he play bishop takes d7
holy cow
i thought he was being very
clever
and he was going to take here
here
and only afterwards take here so let's
see why he did what he did
okay that better be a good reason
i'm sure there is okay so bishop takes
d7
how weird is this by the way it's not
often you see a position where like
almost all of white's minor pieces are
hanging the bishop on e4 is hanging the
knight on b1 is hanging with check the
bishop on e3 is
attacked but it's not quite
hanging
if only white could castle the other way
maybe
this looks really really this i tell ya
i mean i don't know what the times are
by the way but i do i do understand
uh chass and human psychology you don't
like your king
being bombed out of you know your castle
position
and you're taking a walk i understand
you know king walkers you know like the
idea of you know getting out of dodge
but for the moment white can't simply do
that because he's got too many pieces
hanging if white were to make a
defensive move
let's say like this
he's got you got survival chances but
really truth
this is just such a nice position for
black you whenever you want it you got
this check which is always very useful
but you don't need it you simply need to
play bishop to c6 bring your rook out
bring your bishop to e5
e4 pardon me and i guarantee you this is
and another great well i don't know
that's only five away it chew chew up
the board but but obviously your idea of
getting your all your pieces out yeah is
superior to that but but just a long
term plan right where really
that that pollen can move by the way i
think that that's very important too
that even while grandmasters are
calculating you know
great material great attacking plans and
bringing their pieces to good squares in
the back of the mind
is like hey you know my ace in the hole
when nothing else worked i still got a
past a pawn that might just bring you
know me glory
so this looks again a very nice position
for nick but it's not a knockout yet
it is not over till it's over you want
to check out the uh spencer games i do
see what's happening there
okay spencer because his game just got a
lot more important with uh you know
every game is more important with the
the strong possibility that niche nick
is going to draw a hole
copy game seven i believe
oh
sorry i did something wrong i apologize
copy game
seven
and there we have it now i mentioned
oh uh
that what was really kind of
bugging
me was this
um uh the fact that white's king was
still stuck in the center of the board
whereas black's king on h8 it might
appear vulnerable at first sight but
there's a lot of defenders in the
vicinity we left it it was h5 okay yeah
we didn't actually see that on the board
but we were analyzing that yeah we were
looking at h5 as well as knight g3 i
think yeah or even knight takes off six
those were the three right
right so h5
okay and now the key moment and this is
where spence
lashed out wow wow
well we're gonna we're gonna hold off on
that top agent of the day award for a
moment
so knight g5 either this is genius or
ignominity i i really do like how all
the archbishops you know
are going for it you know we're not
holding anything back you know we're all
just trying to ram it down the throat if
it doesn't work you know we left it out
there you know as they say you know we
left it on the field yeah our king on
the ground
we left it on the wheel you know
in a blazer collaboration
going down in a blaze of course now i'm
not a big fan of what white just did by
the way i i i mean i'd spank spencer you
know five ways to sunday for first play
because i'm not impressed
but after ooh
i gotta consider that a major error
taking on h6
uh that gives spencer
good reason to be optimistic so king g8
well i'm just wondering what the heck is
going on here bishop
because you got to be really careful
here for
black i mean
well of course i mean a king a takes
takes
is like one of those positions where
again black's king looks like it could
be loose
but in reality white still got the same
issues with his king and you can cut you
can shut down the g file when necessary
with g4 i'm just thinking that whether
it's good or bad
i mean this is what spence played for
right i mean you're allowing this h file
to be open and bishop takes g5
so that's two pieces and a rook
for the queen
wow so this this is the the live game
board
i believe we're on the live uh i believe
this is the position
that yes this is so we're up to date two
pieces
two miners and a rook
for the queen i love the count one two
three four
so spencer's got 19 points if you just
go by points and then 16 is up to 18 19
20 21.
so if you're just going by the points
spencer's down 21 to 19. right and
that's interesting the way you did it
versus the way i do it the way i do it
is i just say okay the material and
balance is white's got a queen
cool so what does black have for it two
minor six and a rook five
yes eleven to nine and a nine there you
go yeah but having said that
in these positions it's really about
king position okay if
if white were on move you know he'd be
playing rook g1 and he'd be going after
black's king right that'd be over
well yes and no i mean so i'm just
saying that if i were an election can
you play rook i would play rook f7
as maybe a starter with the idea to meet
rook g1 with rook g8 or to be able to
double like this now i think that black
is obviously black is winning materially
yeah
we can't dispute that but it's really
about black's king or white's king in
this case
uh who can get their first with the
mostest and i think
after rook f7 black
king is safe it's well safe as a
relative
black has a lot of defenders let's say
yeah the really bad thing that
spencer's gonna have you know a very
uphill battle to win this is because
he's got nothing to attack in this
position at all right so these guys are
not targets in any meaning by any means
no they're very solid so we could play a
move like rook h1
um how do you say uh
you know threatening to threaten
and let's say rook g8 queen h and you
know black just kind of makes a
a frontal barrier if you will
and
one day one day maybe not too far in the
future that night is then gonna end up
in a very beautiful central by square
and black is looking very good
unfortunately in this game very good
so
the way i would put that one in is
spencer has little to no winning chances
while his opponent does yes
yes exactly but but spencer could
theoretically get a perpetual check down
the line so at the moment we're thinking
uh
nishnak
is making a draw yeah
this is the position that i have so yeah
so niche neck draw
yeah rosenthal
we can't write down anything yet on that
one well we're just looking very good in
that game we're looking good yes
uh ocobian let's go to that game again
because that's uh
very important let us and again this is
our
war 2
copy
game
yes sir i have a question i heard that
if it's a 2-2 match tie that st louis is
eliminated and dallas moves on explain
this whole uh concept sure okay so uh we
played ten regular season matchups right
and uh both of us finished six and a
half
three and a half
with the same record however
uh dallas got the
tiebreaker and they won the uh division
title over us because they had more game
points in the regular season while you
might have been winning matches two and
a half one and a half they were winning
their matches three to one for example
right right exactly that was the type so
they tabulated more game points not many
more but but they did it and so you know
and as their prize you know they've got
uh draw odds in this match but we got
the color choice
get awesome bring them in
bring them in everybody's excited about
the uscl playoffs
uh yeah a water would be excellent too
okay boss man
yes sir
yeah you're on live uh live tv right now
buddy
yep yep that's a massive screen time
oh my god oh my god
so exciting
so we did see the moon
yeah that was your 15 minutes of fame
it's over now it's over seconds 15
seconds of fame
uh rook d4 this is where we uh had left
it rook takes
f2
rook takes f4 rook c8
and now rook c4 actually i was i was
kind of anticipating him playing that
actually
okay now but i don't know if it actually
solves the problem
well there's a lot of problems that uh
white now has
these two rights are in a very
unpleasant
uh circumstance because uh
essentially
white is forced to bring his king oh
that's uh
to a very
unhealthy square
interestingly
pardon me
you just lose the night unfortunately
yeah but at the end of the day
black will have uh
an extra pawn in this rook ending all
right
yeah
yeah dumb yeah it does
yeah yeah black
it's not just the extra pawn it's also
the superior position of the king and
the superior position of this rook this
rook
is ready to zoom over to h4 keeping this
guy passive
and uh
yeah this this difficulty of
understanding the lesser evil
in this case i would probably want to
keep the pieces on the board rather than
give them
give one of them
go into a rook ending let's put it that
way
uh so after king b2 i hit this fellow
and let's say i go here with a nasty
thread
nasty threat so then you go back
now i'm in a pin now i'll attack this
rook
now this rook is likely to go over here
anyway
now at some moment my only chance is
connected with this pawn so i'll move my
rook here
hoping that you take which is by the way
probably winning for you check
king here
now on a very glorious day yeah you need
to get the
nine on c5 or e5 fast
um
this should simply be winning for black
uh
these connected past pawns but
it's white's essentially only chance so
kobien looks very good in this game and
let me just see the latest and greatest
cobian i mean this goes without saying
because a very very good end game player
so you don't become one of the best in
the united states
and king b2 by the way was in fact the
kobe lee's uh move
uh the queen ending looks fine
uh
let's see um
is is rosenthal about to knock him out
yet or let's have a look-see
copy game eight
and we're up to date
we left it basically here bishop takes
d7 was the move that we had left correct
and instead of moving his bishop or
moving his knight or doing anything uh
dallas
so at this point
uh c6 i mean
he should just
take the knight with chuck right
i mean what's what's the delay what's
the delay yeah i think
just do it personally i would just do it
yeah i mean
it's not a bad move i'm not getting paid
by nike to say that by the way i would
just do it
take it force the bishop right
backwards
i would take it
i would lose uh
the
i wouldn't lose i would trade the
bishops and after queen takes i would
want to play rook
to get my rook into the game
that's
uh the worst case now the best case is i
can improve upon that
uh variation i just showed by by being
crafty
so the only other alternative in this
position is bishop the c8 right
there may be a reason i can't think of
it right offhand but there is a knight
b2 check
to uh force the king and
maybe
you you you always look at
oh sure
but okay bishop c8 is another uh
potential move
then this bishop has to go somewhere i
think it should block
the d well this is well
okay well let's
okay okay
i'm sorry i was talking about in after
c6 in this position if we don't take the
knight our only other alternative is to
play bishop to c8 that's right
yeah
if we haven't done that yet yeah right
but he obviously he should just take the
knight check
well there's one other thing that you
want to consider is taking the bishop
with check
take that and now take the knight look
at the rook
and now we could go into some ending
that might look like this
uh oh we don't even have to go into that
ending we could go here
and we've got an ending that might be
very attractive it's a it's a rook
ending where black has an extra pawn
and a better king yeah
but
but it's not a knockout it's not a
knockout no it's not anything can happen
you would hate to be one and a half one
and a half and half to win that for the
to advance for the championship true
enough but still uh nikki's looking good
all right
okay so we gone through the whole uh
gamut yes
okay that's very good you want to go
back to niche nick to see if it's still
a draw
all right just very briefly well no
problems at all let's have a look
and uh okay
enough said
well
well not much progress has been made
the king
is a little bit more active that's
useful
and now the question is
what happens if we go with galloping
dorothy
that's go takes yeah well
let's go takes
takes
and now let's just find out
okay i'm pretty
uh i'm a simple
kind of guy
i want to move that pawn
essentially up the board
and then you'll just get a check
non-stop here right
is that's the question do i just get
checked non-stop
check
check
don't oh okay okay okay yep
be careful
okay but the problem is
i might be just walking to some kind of
massive perpetual check kind of
variation that i can't get out of on the
other hand
when i have white in such positions
there's really only two results
i win because my passport or
it's a draw right i don't lose i mean i
i can't lose the game
unless i walk into a mate but barring
you know you better give me a perpetual
check to save the game that's really
right and that's a success by the way
amongst grandmasters
you know if you get a situation where
only two results are possible
you've done your job i mean you've
gained a big advantage now besides the
move queen takes c6 by the way
it's not like a hundred percent i have
to you know do an all or nothing kind of
uh situation
uh
on a very good day
i might be able to somehow use my king
to get to c5
let me see if i can't demonstrate what i
mean by that um
first of all i need to
control your queen
so let me control your queen for example
by moving my queen here so if you give
up that square can you just play like
queen to e6 then yes i think that that's
a very
uh
decent and fair move on your side but
what if well i want to play b5
so what i was trying to say and probably
not doing a very good job
is
okay in my dream world i'd have
something like this
why do i consider this a dream for white
because essentially it's two versus one
i've got a king and a queen
you've got a question
your king is not
in
the fight right yeah and i'm
i'm trying to throw in ideas like king
i'm trying to bring my queen up here i'm
trying to go you know
in short you know
i've got more space and an active king
you've got an active queen always
lurking to give me perpetual checks
but again um
white for choice uh those two results
that are possible uh by the way these
times are right or wrong they're they're
incorrect i would i would imagine uh
holt has about 28 minutes if i had to
just guess
okay let's just see if i can
yeah i i need a refresher or something
the board i'm not quite sure i got that
uh i'll do
uh nishnek holt again
oh here it is
um
26 minutes to 23. so 23 minutes and so
the time control in this event is 75
minutes with a 30 second increment no
second time control so every time they
move they get an additional 30 seconds
added to their the bonus starting from
one yes very good
and that's
from the season through the playoffs
right yeah it never changes so all the
all the players have been acclimated
with this time control and by the way uh
in the game of
var leon var
um
kind of
pretty much following some analysis that
we gave
copy
game
what was it six
yeah okay so
i was mentioning that uh
i want i would i wouldn't want to go
into that rook ending dan that you
mentioned i would want to keep the
pieces why try to do that but at the
moment there's a lot of pawns behind
knight d1
not a big fan
rook h4
and these knights are looking
very uh
passive right
i mean yeah they don't they're not
trying to check they're just trying to
just capture right that's the problem
they're trying to avoid capture whereas
black
has very uh clear intentions of winning
this pawn yeah then he'll have a three
to nothing majority
presuming
any trade these yeah we would almost
uh love a trade of those pawns because
really we were saying that white's only
claim to fame really is that d-pawn if
he could somehow get that rook behind it
which is possible now and you know check
and then get a knight on e5 c5 do some
checks and run him off the board there
but yeah if he trades those pawns i mean
it's
i'll write down that i'll write down the
game right now
you know well that's very brave yeah
very brave okay uh let's go to
gaming
shall we
uh copy gaming
let's see if rosenthal ever took the the
knight with check
so i'm sure he did so okay we have seen
the move c6 yeah
we
saw chick takes and now check this out
bam
that is something we well at least i did
not analyze bishop takes c6 king e7
and the cute part here is basically
dickey says as soon as i give you a
check
i'll drive the king in a way in such a
way
that i'll end up capturing this bishop
as well this looks
beautiful this looks like a winner
stone cold winner so i think rosenthal
saw var's game and said
you're not gonna get game of the week
what a shocker what a shocker of a move
nice
so
we're looking good on all the board save
spencers he's spent poor spencer's
taking on all the sins
on his shoulders but the one thing good
about spencer is uh he's got a chance
for a perpetual with that queen you know
it's sometimes tough to make a lot of
progress you know
even if you have four to two in the
piece advantage when you're when you're
when all your pieces are just
surrounding your king and not getting
checkmated right so spencer even though
he's down those two points in material
he's still the aggressor in that game
all right let us uh let's have a look
here
where are we spence
nope i've got uh
ah that's because i've got rosenthal's
position up aha and by the way it's just
so beautiful you know
you can't get off the board
nikki's opponent has has chosen to
sacrifice his queen
so
rosenthal is very very so so we were
actually going over that uh before the
game
is um you know if if if we're tied one
and a half one and a half
and have no legitimate chance to win the
the game like in that queen upon end
game and your opponent is playing very
fast just sacrifice your queen and maybe
he'll like you know if he's moving fast
he's just like on a king march or
something so he's just expecting you to
check him and move it back so when he
moves his king
like unbeknownst to him oh i didn't
actually check your king i
i just threatened your
your unopposed your unprotected queen
i'll just take a queen and then we'll
win two and a half
because if we just take the draw two two
and we're out okay so so you're you're
you you you've warned your team i've
played your team
yes that's exactly that's what i'm
saying
we in the barbaric northwest salute you
okay uh let's see uh copy
oh oh this is
this is game seven i should
memorize these games yeah so it's five
six seven eight yep okay
so
unfortunately it appears that dallas
has taken my advice and played
the solid move rook f7
in preparation for spencer's rook h1
rook f8 so we're h2
knight came here threatening to check
all right came back this is a very very
big beast this centralized knight
is looking really good unfortunately
queen h6 so preventing the rook from
taking the pawn obviously
would leave a checkmate and one on the
board but now this move
has a nasty idea of forcing the king and
then yep okay
so that was why he sees it he sees it
yes step back and now rook g7
we got a massive defense message a new
nasty threat
so this time what about king e1 here
then
and i think spence is on move so you're
recommending king e1
looks
okay
i'm not afraid of either check
well maybe i should be
but i'm not i'm not i'm not you're a
brave man a brave man
we recognize
that
okay
i'm not a big fan of this pin if i were
in black shoes
i would probably be inclined to just
step over here i got really bad news the
bishop's still in a in a dream pin
because if he moves
well that's older
what i what i was just just get them all
over there just yeah i mean i know it
sounds cause you've got unlimited time
here you know i'm just going to make an
exit stage left right you know like get
out of dodge if i ever get my king
nicely sheltered on the queen side well
then all my pieces can flood go after
black white's king
so i mean that's the slow
leisurely plan
the other plan
actually and this is pretty bad too your
queen
as you mentioned you know like whenever
it's hovering around the king there's
always those purpley chances
there's a good reason to just get rid of
it just push the queen
as far away from your king as you can
well
the one thing about
that is it allows queen yep
you got it queen to e6
okay
oh sorry let's make the move i was just
like pointing out that as a possibility
without making
okay
g6
queen to c8 check
and you got nothing
that's the end of those checks but i
agree that i wouldn't want to invite the
queen to e6 so probably
i know it looks strange but i would bear
maybe like a move like b6 anticipating
that when this king
gets all the way over here it'll find a
nice home and in the meantime by making
the
the pawn structure all united
the the base pawn c7
i got protected
and then it's just a matter of
matter of time
slowly slowly that should be going
very nicely in the flavor you know
what's with
you know
spencer always has you know he'll
probably have the possibility and if if
that happens he'll probably have to
sacrifice the queen for either two rooks
or the rook and the uh and a minor piece
if he can get it if he can get it right
yeah but that's what he'll be going for
and then just be down a piece and a
broken bishop let's let's take a quick
look at that game and
uh the spencer game and see uh dispenser
games so you can see the uh see what the
uh the a pawn is so he's got the
opposite color bishop end game okay so
it could come into play
hopefully to get the draw
i'm thinking way down the line right so
if if like for instance spencer trades
the queen for the knight and the rook
and then trades off the rooks and a lot
of the pawns
the a pawn with the bishop can't ever uh
you know win the game so
long-term long-term possibilities but
but hey we gotta think of any way to get
a draw out of this
this could be the difference between uh
i like your positive attitude you're
right
yes we can
i mean yes we can
so b2b3
and
black to play uh black's looking very
good why did he just he played the move
rook f8 that was very interesting oh
hold on i've done it wrong as usual
copy game seven
um
i think
yeah so we go ah he played queen eight
i'm wondering how black got by me white
got his queen to h4
so
not to allow even the possibility of
queen d8 we see rook f8 b3 and now this
is the position we have on the board
this is an up-to-date position
it
to my eyes i would play the move b6 okay
so now white needs to make a pass move
and
i'm not sh it's not that easy to
just make a pass move
uh let me throw out one what i would
like to do is i'd like to take this
night okay i've talked about one winning
plan which is to get your king here
here let's be a little bit more
direct give me the queen
so the idea is if you go back to h6
with your queen i can play knight here
to g5
and so my idea behind knight to g5 is
besides pardon me besides rook takes f2
i also want to play knight e4 just
like that
and if we go back here if you go rook g1
to
now we're defined
we got rook f5 and every then the knight
blocks everything there's no open g file
there's no
sacrifices on h7 or g7 and again black
is ready to
start pushing i think
i think
atulia yeah i think he's just going to
play the more patient uh
variety because he's really a no rush
here right and he shouldn't be that's
that's so you know you you're so eager
when you're winning you know you want to
win
and uh oftentimes uh to really win the
winning position you just milk it slowly
you have to show
restraint and patience but uh
that's
that works more often than like a rose i
thought yeah yeah let's see let's see if
he's uh like i've been talking about the
knockout for like 45 minutes now but he
he's a no rush for the knockout by the
way they gotta reach the rook ending
remarkable almost uh
you gotta give his opponent um
but
unlike in that one uh variation that
danny was talking about we are
much better much better much better
counter baby
okay we had left it around these parts
yeah you got that
we'll show
the uh show the awesome move that he
plays so in this position instead of the
bishop c8 move
he's just like i don't care
bishop takes c6 well it was funny
because you will recall perhaps i had i
had considered this situation
where
i'd wanted to bring the rook to the d
file it's kind of remarkable that he
he said i want to bring the rook to the
defile and i'm willing to sacrifice
bishop for it
okay
see i i mean i showed restraint
sacrificing nikki's pieces okay so we
got to this position queen d3 basically
the only move rook d8 this is uh snap
crackle pop uh nikki's winning king up
took
oh
what a cute variation
let's see
what could he have done instead
the question
that looks very attractive however it's
the same i think it's the same thing
this is very
nasty
i don't know so so can you go back to
bishop take c6 no way i can't go back
that far so did he really screw it up by
now no no no no no no
no no no no he's winning he's winning
right right right so he didn't screw up
anything relax he just oh no he did it
because because yeah yeah he has to play
king e7 because he's got to have his
king protecting uh d8 okay correct cool
cool okay but this is all good this is
all good no panics
so we won the guy's queen
so i've seen the live position so i'm
happy but right so yeah
so now
but the the body count is still severe
by the way
rook comes over to c3 very nicely check
it out check it out
that's uh two pieces on around pre
rook to b3
now this one is actually tough
because
the minor piece end game is also very
attractive
correct you know rook takes pawn takes
and i think the only reason why he might
not have done this is because he won't
have two past pawns in this variation
exactly whereas in this variation here
where in the in the game he gets right
he would have
zero past pawns actually in in the minor
piece end game so this is all very good
ooh
that's a confusing move i think many
people would have simply played b4
with the intention of forcing a king and
pawn end game thanks to this outside
past pawn
uh confusing move king d7
it's okay
brooke here
king c8 that's okay i'm a little
confused
rook there clearly what
nikki wants
to do and the reason he played king c8
is he is anticipating
coming back with his rook
defending his position
and then it game over yeah essentially
shepherding his pawns
with his king up the board all right so
so the updated scoreboard unofficial
is we have a win on board four
draw on board one
so we need one more point and we're
expecting a bar to win but we're
expecting it's not in the
winning position
all right so nikki's got a winning
position so let's check let's
yes yes danny
oh because we because he's gonna put the
the question was uh earlier
to not allow the bishop check on a3
why couldn't he go to f7 it was because
the king has to protect d8 when his rook
moves to d8 it has to be protected
so we got here oh the question being oh
okay okay so so he's saying okay so king
f7 with okay so we're
now we got a chat all right g oh
and now we've got some
nasty count you've always got knight v2
uh but we've got some nasty counter play
in this variation queen f6 dan i think
that
is
the likely explanation yeah i i like the
way he played it
obviously
yeah we got the winning position is what
we got
uh king e7 very confusing move there uh
i'm sure uh like i say b4
and let them
let those dog eat so that's that's not
very complicated to calculate right not
at all but but this this way by the way
is a very
um
certain
way as well i mean okay your rook takes
up a passive station but it holds
everything on the king side
and then eventually it gives your
opponent absolutely no hope
just
demoralized demoralized dallas
it's looking good for the bishop okay
let's see what we got here okay we're
gonna close that one up
and by the way uh nikki's doing very
very nicely uh let's get an update on
that game if you don't mind even though
we left it just a moment
sure sure
so our history with the dallas destiny
uh is not a new one we've uh played them
last year did you talk about that sure
yeah we played them in the uh in the
actual uscl championship match the
finals yes because we were in uh
different divisions i believe last year
and uh so there was no draw odds in the
playoffs at all last year so we had uh
wesley soh on the top board
var kobien on board two
uh and then larson on board three
matthew larson who is now uh
going to a prestigious university
and uh then we have uh spencer on board
four
and uh larson and spencer unfortunately
lost
and but resley so defeated conrad and
varkobian uh or liam no it was it was
var
he played uh jeffrey john with the black
pieces the e4 e5 right you know d6 where
you trade off the queens right away it
just played a long end game and for one
so it was tied 2-2 unlike in this game
where dallas has draw odds
uh
it was uh it's called a gauntlet blitz
match so it was great yeah it was great
so so if you win you eliminate the
opponent and uh move on so spencer who
lost in case you draw both players all
players
so spencer was playing on board
three last our board four last year and
he was actually playing the same
gentleman uh karthik who he
who he lost to so he was really geared
up for the match and he he eliminated
him by beating him and then they had uh
frank guadalupe number two
uh
playing on board three and they drew
so he eliminated him
then jeffrey eliminated spencer
eliminated larson so they had some
traction
but then var just took care of business
he uh eliminated jeffrey beat him twice
and then uh
he got uh conrad in the final
so we didn't even need wesley so we had
him in reserve so that was a lot of fun
and that's how we won the uh the
championship last year last year uh
our manager was uh alex marlar and he
was very relieved not to lose his job
no he got fired
he was out
yeah so so it was a lot of fun last year
i was uh
i was the assistant manager last year of
the team but
according to the trophy you never know
it you never know so yes
yes sir why don't we have that crazy
gauntlet blitz playoff this year
yes we would in case of it yes so so
unfortunately
and actually they just have
they have a poll on the top of the
usjustly.com website should playoff
matches between two teams whose seating
difference is one
like
us
be decided via draw odds or a blitz
tiebreaker blitz tiebreaker wins 75 to
25
so the fans love it the teams love it
the commissioner
and i guess yeah yeah all that extra
work yeah so that only the blitz
gauntlet is uh reserved for the
championship and not these uh
not these matchups
coming up to it we have a very unpopular
commissioner running the league
that that that's the basic answer right
i mean that's what i'm hearing
okay by the way
uh in the game after move 33 we had the
move rook h3
we saw h6 as expected rook g3 rook c7 as
expected
hey look at this they followed every
perfect
and this is now
it's nikki's turn to say hey looky looky
i got two connected past pawns on the
queen side rook g3 king came up
rook
dropped over to see seven i'm still kind
of confused yeah that that seems no
reason to uh undefend the uh the e6 bond
right i mean okay um
i'm looking at something like g5 but
okay this is fine yeah
check and now black to play okay if i
was in black shoes i would definitely be
inspired to play the move g5 here
basically by playing g5 it means that
you can't slide your rook over to g3
anymore and keep me tied down i'm well
prepared to meet rook d6 check with rook
c6 okay
and
this okay
hold up here hold up here okay okay so
go go back one move for white okay so
instead of the check yes in this
position yes
what if we just decide to be funny and
play rook h3
uh funny man uh rook h
uh rook h3 i'm like you can take my f
pawn but i'm gonna get your uh
so you get that guy yup okay well let's
see i'll take this you'll take
this okay
so i will okay now i'm coming after you
your unprotected f pawn you mean
something like this yep
and i'm coming after your unprotected
e-pawn all right but now but now i have
hope because i got i got that h pawn
that h-pawn isn't much of a hope
well it's a hope though
you got something to hang your hat on at
least uh yeah that is true i can go down
here and check yeah
i don't know where you're supposed to go
well
i'll go down and just check you some
more
it looks pretty bad um
in view of rook h3 g5
i would think about it i i think g5 is
fine let me just get an update on the
game for a second mike because i do
believe
that more moves have been played no so
we do have this position so once again
h5 a very reasonable good move rook h3
very reasonable good takes takes
here here now let me just
be
crude let me just push these guys
what can you do check
the king and just
get these guys going
you can go h4
right so so so my whole question is
why even bother with g5 when you have
this beautiful plan of just
marching these pawns down his throat
yeah it's sort of like
grandmasters are greedy we want to have
our cake and eat it
if we're better on one side of the board
we're happy
but wouldn't it be better if we were
better on both sides of the board
i just like it being locked down
yeah yeah no no no we're greedy and uh
uh so if i could turn that kingside
situation into super stable and
everything i'm attracted to that
but just going with the
with the with the doggies on the queen
side by the way
something confusing but i think they
played our variations
all right
oh wait which game
our game all right or the game we're
watching okay with the uh
where he's got the the age pawn now yeah
he they play i mean uh
i'm gonna have to take nicki out to
dinner he's doing great
okay but he did it in a different way i
beg your pardon he just started with a5
he didn't play games with g5 and only
after check did he
now he played g4 okay but he got two
tempe
so he did it far better than i did and
now we get the same variation
and look familiar yes except that eight
pawns not on a6
it's all the way up the board on a4
king a5 escorting the pawn
and we've got this position on the board
so we're expecting b4 no no no rook
takes a3 check
aren't we expecting rook to see five
no i think i
you're the one who liked pushing the
pawns now you suddenly want to defend
and re-catch your pawns watch i gotta
get that i gotta get that
look
that's the way i think but you you you
taught me that i should just be pushing
the pawns and it looks very strong mike
you don't need to go after the eve pawn
these pawns are winning the the game on
the spot actually seriously okay this is
all very very good just push these guys
and check
and look you know you just
it's there it's just there this is just
yes
kevin has a question how long would it
take a grand master to calculate that
basically to the end and say
i can see this pond
they don't they don't uh there's no
necessity for them to calculate to the
end they just have a certain pattern and
awareness
i got that
i got the game
so they don't go
all the way to promoting the pawn they
get to this position they already have
to stop they don't need to calculate any
further and in fact they will play it
very very quickly
just because they recognize
that pattern is gold yeah it's just one
marvelous
uh
it's also very uh heartening to see nick
playing this end game so
you know very very well by the way once
again i'm going to bring out this game
for a second because
it really is instructive
um
how
nick has played this
uh
check it out we had left it
way back here
by the way he played it the way you
wanted to play it okay that is a rook
takes out so where he gets the pawn back
yeah there he goes he goes oh he played
this way to protect the pawn i don't
really like that
activating the king no this is very good
play trust me
this is really awesome
look at this now he's threatening mate
in two
very straightforward check
followed by mate
so rook i'm over
rook up behind threatening mate so i
gotta play king c1 and now it's uh
rook rook uh well
what would you do mike how would you how
about how about work a4 rook
a4
so your intention is but but the thing
is this is tricky now that he's got that
past e pawn though right let's just take
the e pawn
please
uh i'm all for
all four i'm all for eliminating the e
pawn probably if i were black i would
play a2 actually here
so my idea oh right because if he pushes
the e pawn we can just take it and laugh
at him
correct
yes yes
and if he gets out of dodge
dodge being shack followed by promote if
he goes here then i would
bring king to b2 so i could win the rook
like that and that's all she wrote
uh and let us just see what nick has
played
uh he played a2
all right good and after e6 i'd
eliminate the pawn with a gain of tempo
right rook takes e6 if i were what if i
oh you played rook a4
oh that's winning two
rook takes a4 b takes a4
and you're promoting the a pawn with a
check
wait a minute wait a minute no rook a4
which takes a4 king takes a4 and then
it's over yeah king takes a
and we can chalk this one up for sure
queen e5
thank you
queen e5 just
eliminating this point oh b takes a4
okay he didn't have to take back with
the king all right now i understand what
happened okay good so we so we can chalk
this one up to good play
good play very good
what did i do now
oh
all right so so we we're this is
official now we have the point it's not
unofficial anymore officially
uh we have a draw in the game of nizhnak
is it is that game it's official it's
official okay it's official that a
cobian has won
and it's official
that
nick won
so we have one game left and it's
immaterial
correct so we're going we're
yes
yes
all right okay let's see
how uh
var k
var brought back the bacon
brought home the bacon
copy
game six i believe
by the way hasn't var been a standout
for
the archbishops this year yes yes so he
uh
he was playing on board one
for the majority of the uh
of the time but then after a week
six we were able to uh bring on uh
niche nick uh he finished up the last
two games so he's now won his last five
or six days
take a seat congratulations thank you
oh yeah join us join us uh
smooth operation or
any any real problems for you uh no i
think it was a good game
i do too
uh
okay this is all standard opening stuff
and
is this pawn sacrifice well known var
yeah i analyzed this a little bit this
position but uh
one line that
computer suggests usually is after you
take
bishop b6 queen c4 97
um takes it takes
c4 here for white
that's right this is the key i think v3
is dubious because i think c4 is
important because after b3 rook g8 i
think black might be already slightly
better because
right and pieces are very active to
bishops it's wonderful yeah it's very
hard i think he kind of played b3 like
he just really wanted to keep the pawn
but
after rook cheat i think bach might be
already slightly better because
i'm not sure how you can realize pieces
and knight on a2 yeah as it happened now
yeah he had a realization like how does
he untangle you know i was thinking that
white might do something a little bit
artificial somehow to get this rook up
yeah it doesn't work but if you pledge
for the knight f6 and knight g4 i'm not
a happy jumper
so came this this
maybe
i thought his intention was to go like
very slowly f3 g3 yeah is it a better
idea or not i think f3 you can play um
yeah i was definitely considering
f3 and then you would like to play g3
maybe i just go h5 here also very
pleasant for you yeah h4 h4
g3 h4 yeah yeah
definitely good compensation yeah
definitely good compensation
well his choice wasn't exactly that much
yeah
very nice either
and now you had a very nice position no
i just wanted to be
did you know that mike
mike suggested that you're team captain
yeah
that's why he's the boss i i got really
afraid when
he started playing mike's move i began
to look you know no but i just might
have some parallel universe here
it's funny i just looked at the position
i think black is just completely
dominating here because uh
i couldn't see any moves for him here
pieces on the back and my threat is very
simple knight c6 and i win the d4 pawn
which i think the game will be over if i
played this one so i think he played the
only move otherwise yeah um
and i was a little bit surprised i think
maybe here he made it a little bit
inaccurate no this is correct sorry
knight c6 i thought i thought you should
play knight e2 here because i don't
think he should allow rook g2
i was gonna play
bishop b8 here
yeah the moment that that rook landed on
g2
really looked like uh yeah
it was
we lost the opportunity to even panic
yeah yeah
i think this is probably his best way to
play um instead of c4 what if knight e3
knight d3 rook takes d4
she's winning upon that it's just a
better end game and no more extra pawn i
would say it's it's almost it's nearly
winning because the double pawn on that
file is just gonna yeah next one g2
i think i can probably win one bishop
end game here because my king just comes
too yeah no it's looking very i think
his only thing he's got to keep the pawn
but uh i think he just definitely
misplayed it here because rook g2 yeah
so afternoon
this is slightly better for me but
maybe somehow his best chance might be
in
with
space now
rook g2 immediately
i want to play luke g2
any chances to some chances
maybe yeah
but this rook is fine i mean i was
actually planning not to even take just
go knight d5 here i really don't want to
take because
then my f5 one will be weak
very pleasant eventually i'll exchange
rooks take back only six i agree so
knight e2 may have been more stubborn
yeah but it's not saving the game no no
he's already worse here i was already
happy because i was a little bit worried
because the spencer position looked very
dangerous yes and ilia was kind of equal
and nikki's position was uh not so
completely clear you know right but in
hindsight he played a really beautiful
game yeah yeah i mean
isn't it this d4 uh
it's known yeah okay it should be but
let's uh okay by this point
you saw a very nice year
because
uh but he's already worse but i think he
might have missed this idea because
probably he could do something else
because but at this point he was hoping
he was probably expecting that your
bishop may have to go back who knows on
a good day the rook could actually also
can go knight g6 there it's also
possible but it's not as strong as got
to
such ideas yeah yeah okay but but once i
saw this idea i was very happy because
it's pretty it's very visual everything
is hanging and rook c4 yeah but i think
it's just lost now but now yeah the
nights are terrible i
take all the pawns and my rooks are very
active yeah so you're having the best of
all possible yeah
now this uh was a very nice thing now
look out comes to f2
f4 is a thread so
i i checked you know this i checked
and you know you probably saw so many
times did you double calculate i checked
i checked i checked
is
yeah you know but you know i you know i
spent like two three minutes just to
make sure the night you know i checked
three times because i don't want to miss
something and then somehow the
imaginance two two you know
it'll be like unbelievable well it's
very painful because you play against
the computers and
you know like you do roxy too as a kind
of like now you resign and then there's
some horrible it was individual game
maybe i'll play more confidently like
it's just my game but like i imagine if
i just
blunder and somehow spencer is worse
maybe he'll lose yeah and then like it's
two two is be unbelievable i just spent
like two three minutes because i had to
check i had the time because
i just wanted to finish nice tactic rook
c2 and just win like this i couldn't i
could play any move actually i'm still
winning there you've been a long time
french defense player played it more
than a decade but
it's still
good money i mean it's still uh giving
you difficulty the specific preparation
because even though i was black i had to
play type of position where i have
chances so i didn't just play rubenstein
or my typical i actually played only
maybe this assistant once
but i was really surprised he was
playing so fast in the beginning yes in
some point he had like 80 minutes so i
thought this guy is well prepared but
i think he just then when he saw b3 he
felt a little bit better as soon as he
played b3 i i was very as soon as he
played beatrix i was very happy because
i thought i cannot be worse than
transition two bishops beautiful
activity open file so i knew that uh i'm
probably gonna have a good game yeah uh
yeah but i was a little bit you know so
i prepped this line a little bit to play
against him but you know he played all
sorts of systems against french so it
wasn't like i was only expecting this
but
i had time to prepare so i'm glad it
worked out well today
very well done good luck in the finals
thank you for your thank you for sharing
with our audience
ilya
nice is my turn now yes
uh
take us through
what has happened unfortunately he
wasn't as impressive as
yeah there were a few interesting
moments i believe okay
so first of all your opponent he has a
reputation deserved one as a french
defense player so you could expect it i
knew that yeah and i thought he plays
only french only so you sit there and go
okay i got this guy he plays a french
defense you have a huge you can play
advanced french you can play winner work
you can play tarash
and you come up with exchange yeah so
how how does take us through your logic
reasoning
actually
while preparing against uh conrad i
i was kind of expecting myself to
to beat him in more of a positional play
you know and and and i saw that uh
choosing exchanged french will be the
best choice for this for this matter
even though you know of course it has a
very big reputation for being drawing
drawing yes yes but i believe in myself
and unfortunately
okay but now you've decided in your
preparation that is you've decided to do
the exchange french
but then there are different approaches
that you can take to the exchange french
like for example you can play the
exchange french with a knight c3 and a
bishop d3
and you chose knight f3 which is fine
and obviously in his games we know that
he likes this line of bishop d6 and it
was this move this this particular yeah
why is this attractive because uh i was
you're taking the isolated queen yes i
was i was actually aiming for positions
that appear after after him taking on c4
thus giving me the isolated pawn on d4
so this is what my
like my goal was to get this very
position unfortunately it didn't work
that well okay so you've got
basically in your mind's eye before the
game in your preparation you're more or
less
this game on your board okay yeah and
you're satisfied because you have better
smoother easier piece play
and
space and you don't mind the strategic
risk of the isolation exactly okay so
you're a happy camper
and after knight c6 you played h3 and he
played h6
and this moment i wasn't a big fan of
your move queen c2
this is actually a quite interesting
move to be honest okay sure because
after queen c2
the main the main answer would be knight
knight b4
yes there will be like two moves after
this queen b3 or queen b1 the balls are
very interesting
um
i won't say much but the positions that
occur after this are like extremely
sharp and interesting so okay this is
was this was my
expectation yeah you would play 94.
and you with the move queen c2 you have
such evil intentions
of bishop takes and queen g6 yes
so
his move knight h5 was not a big
surprise
he needs to drive your bishop away of
course yeah i was expecting that so
bishop d3
yeah so here for some reason in this
position instead of bishop e6 people
usually play knight c6 and i was i was
trying to find
to find out why
black black do that because
bishop b6 seemed like a normal move for
an actual game so
presumably yes i started worship e6 yeah
so now i have like b4 and this is
probably slightly like slightly slightly
better for white probably especially
okay yeah but but yeah but if we play a
very logical move
bishop e6 and now you're scratching your
head wonderfully yeah yes
and everybody play visually exactly so
so my first idea was that i can probably
play that e5 here right but then
c5 and i wasn't sure if if i'm if my
position is okay because it looks like
something is going to go wrong exactly
he's going to play queen 67 next move
and i'm already not sure what's what's
happening
and if you play something as
no no maybe instead of taking he could
play queen c7 you do have knight b5
though oh i'm sorry yeah i'm sorry yeah
so
but it looks
strange all the pieces in the middle of
the board without the protection of the
yeah
right yeah it's like why are
why is that happening so yeah i mean i
decided to yes sorry i decided to
basically
use this idea but
but include rocky one first yes exactly
well you know we we call the move rookie
one vladimir kramnik's move because
because in like almost all positions he
finds the useful move rookie one and we
know
from vladimir games that it's just
useful so just to get extra protection
from anything who knows he doesn't even
know half the time but the rook on e1 is
a good move okay so now came knight e5
and you were expecting
now you're ready to meet c5 with dc i
suppose c5 dc or even bishop e3 would
have been fine but but the fact that my
my opponent played knight c6 without any
hesitations actually it's annoying and
it actually made me really really
surprised because like to to go for this
kind of positions where you have double
pawn on c file it's
if you if you plan accurately you may
end up playing very very unpleasant end
game
this is why i was so surprised he played
it so
so fast
right
so yeah but again even having said all
of that
it's a little bit unsettling that he has
these double palms but the problem is
your bishop on c1 is not an effective
piece yeah that's right that's right and
here this was the moment where i made my
first mistake oh you're first oh yes
because there's only one more yes yes
so you have played a3 which is
completely useless because of
upcoming move yeah okay what should you
have played um
the narrow move would probably be bishop
d2
okay yeah developing a bishop
and you rejected it because
because
because of knight d5 but 95 is not
really a strat i i was i didn't want to
allow him to exchange his knight for a
bishop so i wanted i kind of wanted to
play that e4 here but
so now we understand why you started
with a3 yeah so that you could meet 95
with 94. exactly but unfortunately it
has a problem yes okay let's see what
the problem was you played eight and the
problem is queen d7
so
he reminded you
you
could you could be tickled over there
exactly so i i completely missed that
idea that i have to i mean i didn't i
couldn't even imagine how to actually
worry about my king sizes
annoying isn't it yes no but did you
played knight e4 but that presumably
stops this threat actually this is it
could be a very interesting one but
actually now bishop is is a mistake
because i don't even have to take on h3
i can just take on f6 and play like some
normal move like
bishop e3 and he's double he had he'll
he's going to be having two double bonds
now
i don't i don't think it's he's a part
of the good but
you mean you will play
f3 mr bishop f1
i don't know
um
it looks strange
i'm just
taking your piece isn't
it all right what's gonna happen
perhaps
uh
let me can you share it yes
yeah but now i can just say queen c6 and
i'm okay
i'm predicting this i think you pardon
me just a second let's do this again i
went rookie six you went king h1
if i take this you just run yeah and i
ran with my kin to f1 very good very
good i get it now okay so king h8 and
pardon me you hit ah i will just taking
on c6 protecting g to pawn very good
annoying
annoying but i didn't
looks okay
so
uh
no but it's only one of the ways yes
so there's a the interesting one would
be oh
yeah it's okay yeah so uh take take on
take on a4 attack on a4 no no instead of
taking on stream oh pardon me the
interesting thing would have been take
on the e4 take on a4 and here he played
bishop f5 but instead he would have
taken on h3 ah yeah so here i have to
probably my only move is to take on h6
to take on h6 yeah because the problem
is if you're taking on g2 he's taking on
h3 and h2 is
very unpleasant so taking on h6 um
actually it's not the only one i'm sorry
i apologize yeah bishop d2 was i was not
removed but i was planning to take on h6
okay and what was your main line how did
it go our bishop takes h6 and now if g
takes h6 uh
he's actually losing after bishop c6
wow queen g4 does he have to take this
no he doesn't have to take this along
yeah so queen g4 and now i just take on
a8
no a8 bishop takes a8 yes interesting
rock takes a hit queen c6
and rook e3 is incoming trapping the
bishop on h3
a nice variation to be sure
so after i saw this i was kind of
ready
it's a very important defensive resource
the queen c6 to defend g2 from the long
diagonal nice resource
all right so that was why he in this
moment
yeah bishop five was a good one right
taking advantage of the pen on the
profile basically forcing me to play
bishop d2 and now here i think he
actually made a mistake okay because in
this position he could have played c5
trying to get rid of his double bones
and i
honestly think i i would have had a draw
yes exactly yeah um
so this was his moment yeah really
because as the game went it was actually
i think he's fighting worse yes this is
some nice play for you
we got to a position later sorry for
going fast but
essentially we reach yes this is a
critical position and actually i
actually still believe that there should
be something for white even even if i
exchange this pair of rogues
um
okay we can we can just go on and and
take a look at what happened in the game
so here couldn't be it yeah maybe
instead of king d2
i had another source
of
queen c5 i believe
yes we looked at something like this but
he was getting
some
unfortunately queen e8 so my idea is to
play queen e5 trying to yes he's not
going to trade queens yeah but yeah so
not 27 i'm actually here i'm actually
probably pretty much better than the
game improvement over the game
yeah but here i don't have any problems
with with some counter play for black
that's the point so here it's liquid d7
he can just play queen f8 this is why
uh i rejected yes i rejected this line
i didn't see what i'm gonna do after
queen of f8 and i just i just have to go
back basically to c5
and then he will go back to e8 because i
like i can i can play b5 for
any time but there is not not much not
much sense because i'm helping him right
well as you played it in the game what
we anticipated was two
um
approaches hold on what do we got okay
we were we were thinking that you were
going to try to take advantage of the
position in two ways this is already i
think it's just ready to draw so so it
went a bit too far one way
we
thought that you would play
was to get your
king to
c4 b4 so let's say i go here yeah so
queen e6
and let's say i go here
but this is already
not much
i
what mean i do
what if queen d5 let's say or queen
oh yeah queen d5 is okay queen d5
so the variation where you get a
a pass d pawn
how
good or not
okay the game could very easily end in
perpetual check right we agree this
might be not enough because his phone
runs pretty fast too
this is probably that is true
how did we got it in a different way
though no we had some
okay i apologize because we were looking
at this type of enough i was i was going
i was going for this position but with
my king actually on b4 or
d6 or somewhere else right exactly yes
that would have worked
okay so let's say you get this position
and we do it at the diff so you do it a
little slower if quincy ford has just
queen f5 check and can if consistently
queen be one getting some control play
is it so true yeah i mean i maybe maybe
not i'm not saying anything but isis
the chances of perpetual check we're
higher than your chances of winning
doubtlessly you are right so you have
probably not probably taken it no no no
no no queen endings are notoriously
difficult as we i very well know i'm not
facing that f3 was a mistake as well
we go back honest yes here f3 and it
appeared to be just a
useless move because
would you have preferred ah i'm i'm
still not sure if if position after
queen e2 queen takes it to king takes it
to his winning for me and this is what i
was going for and this is what i should
have gone for i think
i'm sure he would if i were in his shoes
i'd be very very reluctant to trade yes
exactly because now
my king gets to c4 and his king gets to
d6 and it all comes down to
do if i can touch one him or not yes
so uh i actually didn't see the way how
i can stick this one
black in this position because if g3 is
and
g6 i suppose
g6
g6 yeah g6
f3
i'm not sure this this works actually
somehow it didn't work
i was calculating this well why not f6
look at f4 now it works why does it work
because i take and
f5 it's at 661
actually oh it's not enough yeah i can
e7 right e7
yeah king d7 and c6
this is probably why still a draw even
you need almost like one
extra tempo more i cannot even play b5 i
was thinking about d5 cd5 b5 but it
doesn't work as well
okay now
now you're making beautiful uh
breakthrough yeah but i'm losing after
this information yeah he has just enough
temples to get his king to to b8 exactly
when he needs it no she's six no you
can't play six no no because i should
just take
oh sorry i've gotta go king b8 right
away oops
sorry sorry you're right
oh dear
oh
yeah
oh well
okay so
one of the problems with queen endings
too is i have discovered in my own
practice you can spend a lot of time at
the board calculating variations
and you calculate very deeply and you're
very proud of yourself
until you come to the sterling
conclusion that one defensive move and
all your calculation is useless like
exactly you go queenie too and the guy
has queen e6 and you've been calculating
forever and ever that you know the king
and pun and name he played queen e7 and
this is sorry
and this is basically where you gave up
your uh
yeah and he found a perpetual check as
well
because now in fact if i try to go for
it um i might end up losing if kf6 i get
matted on the spot
if king d2 i he gets my opponent on d4
by checking on d2
so now if we need to check in f4 for
example
i'm sorry then he has this nasty move
exactly and
it looked quite dangerous already
because now he has a passport
exactly oops
so you didn't go for that variation but
instead allowed
the uh oh sorry
what happened was this where you agreed
to um
yeah it might be but yeah anyway your
intention was king d5 yes i'm so queen
a2 and now i can do nothing because
because now if king c5 and queen queen
skin c6 like he just takes on a4 with
his chakras and then d4
and if knc5 and queen a3 check and pin
b5 queen b3 and i i i'm risking to get
made on b6
very good very good
oh well
okay sometimes it's
well played the game by your opponent
exactly he found a very good i mean very
good counter play by by activising his
queen that was very well played by him
well very good elliot thank you and
congratulations good luck in the finals
thank you for coming and sharing sure
your viewpoint
well there we have it everybody i think
uh the match is well and truly over let
me just check
the final result was unfortunately
spencer did lose
so the final result in the match was two
and a half one and a half st louis to
the final and that's all that matters
ben simon here by the way mike cummer
has stepped out for the night so i'll be
here before you close the show yasser uh
big news that we know in the u.s chess
league tonight we defeated our rivals
the dallas destiny two and a half to one
and a half that magic number and because
dallas had draw odds i heard someone say
they described this match earlier as a
tall order for st louis to fill but we
did and we're moving on to the final
once again and we're in the main event
so to speak in uh of just a few weeks
after thanksgiving december 1st it's a
tuesday night we will be playing the
manhattan applesauce
and i'm so glad we're going to be able
to say we're playing the manhattan
applesauce because it's the best name
ever they defeated the new york knights
uh just uh a few moments ago
man those guys could have played in the
same room if they wanted to right
nyc so that's going to be really
exciting we're taking a couple weeks off
and we're going to bring this stream to
you in just a few more weeks on tuesday
december 1st really exciting stuff we're
going to defend that championship yasser
right well let's hope we can turn the
big apple into applesauce all right well
i'll let you close the show and what a
good night it's been thank you ben and
thank you all for having join us here at
icc and in st louis at the st louis
chess club and scholastic center we hope
you enjoyed the coverage and uh once
again well done archbishops go go go
until next time december 4th or
1st first
see in december
good match guys good match
very good
that that makes it extra nice actually